how's it going everybody it's Warren and
today we have some really big news in
regards to venom 2 as we have our first
leaked video of Cletus Kasady otherwise
known as the person who inherits the
carnage symbiote and thanks to this
leaked video it seems like we may have
discovered how exactly Cletus is going
to go on to get the symbiote and many
fans will be happy to know that Cletus
Kasady no longer has that horrible red
wig let's take a look at the video now
we know that Cletus was in prison and we
know that somehow he gets out now we
don't know if he gets the carnage
symbiote - while he's in prison and
carnage helps him break out or if he
gets it after he breaks out but as we
can see here in this video of Woody
Harrelson as Cletus Kasady a detective
or a cop of some sort comes up to him
tells him to put his hands in the air
and then the cop just starts shooting
him and this is most likely because
carnage makes an appearance because it
doesn't make sense that a cop would tell
him to freeze put his hands on his head
and then just start shooting him clearly
something happened and not to mention
the cop seemingly unloads a full clip
into Cletus Kasady and he's completely
unharmed in fact he just stands there
like nothing even happened at all and
the most likely cause of this is that
carnage appeared and took all of the
bullets for Cletus much like we saw
venom do for Eddie Brock in venom and
not to mention if you take a look at how
he raises his hands he does it very
confidently and very nonchalant like he
knows nothing is going to happen because
he has carnage with him he knows that he
can't get hurt because he's most likely
been attacked before and carnage has
most likely saved him
bullets are completely ineffective and
useless to a symbiote we also have our
very first leaked photo of Cletus Kasady
now there really is no context to this
photo to know anything that's going on
but we can't see that his character is a
little bit different in appearance and
the post credits scene of venom we saw
Cletus Kasady and he had a very very bad
red wig on now it still looks like he
has red hair in this photo but it looks
like he kind of got a haircut which
means the studio heard the complaint
from fans of
about the wig so we're getting leaked
photos and leaked videos of Woody
Harrelson's character Cletus Kasady that
seemingly have carnage in the same shot
this means that it's only a matter of
time until we get our actual first look
at carnage which would make sense and be
right on track as venom two comes out on
October 2nd of this year 2020 which also
means that we should be getting some
photos very soon of Cletus Kasady and
Eddie Brock together possibly of venom
and carnage together finally so let me
know what you think about this leaked
video and about this leaked photo what
do you think about Cletus Cassidy's new
look and how excited are you to see
carnage and venom - let me know your
thoughts in the comments down below also
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe what notifications turned on
so you can enter my giveaway for a
chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4 the
winner gets to choose and I'm picking a
winner at five hundred and fifty
thousand subscribers join my discord if
you'd like to talk to fellow marvel at
DC and superhero lovers and as always
thank you all so much for watching we'll
foof